hi I'm Evan Carmichael walk another
edition of ask Evan in stage episode I'm
going to answer question from Eric who's
one of my Facebook friends and he asked
about my setup for making his videos he
wrote in saying I've been what kind of
camera and mic do you use it's crystal
clear also to use a tripod to elevate
the camera above you I do a weekly
announcement for my industry and I want
to upgrade the appearance so thank you
for the question Eric a great question i
get asked at a number of times so it's
great to be able to answer this on video
for you guys i'm a big believer in
starting off any venture any new project
really cheap investing your time for not
investing your money so when I started
doing video I did it myself and I use a
quick little flip camera that was was
pretty basic and then I slowly started
upgrading my equipment as I was able to
get a few sponsors and make a little bit
of money from the video so it wasn't
just a loss as I as I turned it out if
you go back to my earlier videos you'll
see they were pretty bad the quality of
the content was still good but the
production quality was pretty bad and I
slowly started increasing the quality of
my equipment now I film in a room in my
basement so it's got a white wall that
looks pretty professional I've got some
lighting on me in terms of the camera I
now use a sony handycam and i basically
got the camera said with the flip and
sort of moving my way up through the
costco camera so i got this one a costco
is it's the highest end one that they
had and the reason i got it was I had an
external microphone jack so my flip was
amazing the new HD flip that was out was
awesome the video quality was awesome
but there was no external microphone so
some people who are watching my videos
we're complaining that it was a great
content but they could hear me really
clearly so I wanted the camera that had
an external microphone jack and it was
great to kind of get feedback from
people saying that so you know making
the investment based on the you know
people who are giving feedback are
actually consuming the content
so there was only one camera classical
at the time of the sony handycam that
had the external microphone jack and now
for the microphones when I do these kind
of presentation when you see me on
camera use a little clip Mike from Sony
and I try to keep it just under the the
line of where you can see me on the
camera so the camera starts what about
here and I have a microphone just sadly
under and I could I could take it off
you guys to see so this is a clip Mike
that I could buy the camera store and
maybe 90 bucks 100 bucks and it plugs
into the side of the sony camera and
it's been pretty pretty great ever since
when i do the the audio only one so if
you see any videos we're doing the
famous entrepreneur seekers and it's
just audio of me or from doing a
screencast and I'm you know you're
watching my screen as I'm talking then i
use a blue microphone it's the Yeti one
ive one day walked into the the apple
store and they had it on sale and i
thought it looked interesting i thought
it could help improve the audio quality
i used to use a headset but i found that
the the Yeti blue was really amazing and
so thank you that you wrote in saying
that you like the audio quality because
we've been working on making it better
and i do use a tripod so when I'm
filming these I have a tripod that's
just a little bit above my head and then
tilted on a downward angle found the
debt that has a good image if you're if
it's a little bit lower than you then
you kind of look like a giant and
quality goes down a little bit so it's
just a little bit above me and pointed a
slight downward angle and I've got six
lights on me that again we're super
cheap bought from ikea and then then got
some really powerful light bulbs from
home depot and they're placed in you
know here here and here all around me
and a couple videos i move my hands and
I and I hit a light so you see that
every now and then but it's it's been a
good setup if you look over my old
videos you'll see I had some at my
office I had the really old ones at my
house when I didn't have a tripod and I
used my flip camera you could see the
camera the screen wobbling a little bit
a little bit hard to to watch as a
viewer but again I'd like starting off
cheap see if it works I could have tried
a couple videos and said you know this
isn't for me I don't want to keep doing
it and then I would have been out a lot
of money on the camera on the lighting
in the tripod so I always make sure I
don't put up put energy at the beginning
see if it works and then as it does
continue to work and we get some results
and I start increasing the investment
and in this case now I'm pretty happy
with the equipment that i have and i
appreciate the comment that you thought
it was professional and crystal clear
quality on the under on the audio so
thank you everybody if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up I hope
that helped answer your question there
the thumbs else makes me want to do more
of these videos few guys and I always
appreciate them and if you have a
question about my setup or another
question about your business feel free
to leave a comment below I always look
at those and I try to answer everyone if
I can so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode
you
you